another great story the hits just keep
on coming
amid
the ongoing lawsuits that are being
leveled against pornhub this is i think
the biggest porn website certainly one
of one of the biggest names in porn it's
owned by a company called mind geek and
i guess they own lots of other
properties and websites too
there are lawsuits now because these
porn sites host child pornography and
rape content and all sorts of
illegal content
and in part this is because the the
limits on who can upload what and and
how the videos stay up and how the
videos are taken down they're not really
well defined it's it's not as though
for every video that's uploaded to one
of these websites they're checking
people's id cards making sure people are
over 18 making sure that the women who
are in these videos weren't drugged or
coerced or anything like that so there's
all sorts of
outright illegal material on these
websites furthermore
all of the material is by definition
obscene we have laws against obscenity
in this country we had laws passed in
the late 1990s bipartisan support passed
to limit porn on the internet and
unfortunately a bunch of groomer creepy
judges shot that down baselessly uh so
you could if you wanted if there were
the political will you could take down
these behemoths right now well
the market might be taking down the the
porn websites before even the political
order will visa
is uh is is now suspending ad payments
on pornhub and other mind geek websites
mastercard had already suspended uh use
on pornhub and now they're suspending
use of its card for advertising payments
on other websites owned by mindgeek
the lawsuit in particular right now that
is doing this
is a woman who said that her boyfriend
uploaded a video of her from when she
was 13 years old 13. it's not like we're
talking at 17 and a half here clearly
this girl must have been very very
underage and yet it was it was
proliferating all around these platforms
and so it's a really clear-cut case
visa mastercard they're not doing this
as far as i'm concerned
we should take down the big porn giants
by
any means necessary
the political order lawsuits obviously
there's some politics involved here then
there's market forces involved because
the companies don't want to catch the
flack and they're getting activists
calling them and saying you're
facilitating child pornography you're
facilitating rape so they don't want it
all i don't care whatever it is there is
no right to porn
there is no right to make money on the
sex sexual exploitation of women and in
some cases children take it down
by the way not only because some of this
content is very very clearly illegal
even if the content weren't illegal
we should still
fight against porn
why
one because it's wrong
but two i don't want to just sound like
the church lady here two because it is
harming a huge number of people in this
country every single week in my mailbag
i get so many questions from young men
who are who are talking about how porn
has ruined their lives we read a study
on the show this was a long time ago
there's a study that the average age
that that a young boy is exposed to
hardcore porn on the internet is like 11
i think
the vast majority of men have looked at
porn at some point in their lives and a
growing number of women have looked at
it and struggled with with the
temptation to look at it as well and
it's really messing them up
you're seeing huge numbers of men who
are experiencing erectile dysfunction
because they've gotten their brains so
turned to scrambled eggs on porn
they they're
they have all sorts of problems in
relationships they're experiencing
depression anxiety
i could go on and i've actually stopped
even reading all of these questions in
the mail bag because they're they're so
repetitive because so many people are
writing in with the exact same problems
and it
porn is a really good issue here because
i i don't think i'm being hyperbolic
when i say
high-speed internet porn is one of the
biggest political problems in america
why because it's in part a technological
problem
20 years ago this did not exist
20 years ago i don't know i guess maybe
you'd say 30 years ago at this point if
you wanted to go look at porn you'd have
to go to the cd part of town and go into
some scuzzy looking shop and you would
there would be enough shame involved in
all of that that you just wouldn't do it
or you'd have to go to the magazine
store and go to the you know the rack in
the back at the top and buy a playboy or
a penthouse magazine or whatever now we
all have portals to hell in our pockets
okay or on our laptops or on our ipads
or wherever
and the sort of porn that is available
is
way more intense than your uncle's
playboy from the 70s okay
way way more intense and it there are
a ton of psychological studies on this
it just really messes people up
and if you if you have you just look at
the statistics on it if you've got a
country where the vast majority of
people are in a state of perpetual grave
mortal sin that they can't escape from
that they want to escape from but
they're too addicted to
that is you are not going to have a
flourishing political order you just
can't
you
a good comparison would be to drugs if
you had a country
where 90 of men and some other large
number of women
were all hooked on heroin all the time
you would not have a good political
order and so i'm all for this wheeled
government power
to stop this stuff
just i would say the same thing for
drugs we didn't get to the brittany
griner story right now
we'll get to we'll get to brittany
griner maybe tomorrow or later on this
week
but
so so many people are complaining about
brittany griner because she's being
sentenced to jail for using drugs
they're saying oh she shouldn't be
sentenced for that long or it shouldn't
be nine years the the sentence in russia
is not unusual it's not like she's just
being selectively prosecuted because
she's an american and it gives them
leverage this just is the punishment for
drugs in russia we used to have much
tougher punishment for drugs in america
we used to have much tougher punishment
for for porn and obscenity in america we
used to have much tougher punishments in
years past and maybe right now you're
trying to grapple with this idea you're
saying look i don't think we should have
tough drug laws i don't think we should
have tough laws on obscenity or sex or
whatever weird kind of vice stuff i
don't think we should have any of that
but then ask yourself this question do
you think america today
is better is a better country than it
was 20 30 years ago do you really think
that you really think 2022 alters to
your abortion transiting the little kids
everyone to especially on the porn issue
totally messed up on this weird sex
stuff highest rates of drug overdoses
ever average life expectancy declining
in the united states driven in large
part by drug overdoses you're really
going to tell me
that all those policies of liberalizing
and letting up and getting rid of some
of those laws you really think that's
worked out i don't think it's worked out
at all they're going to call us when we
want to reinstitute these kind of rules
they're going to call us authoritarian
fascist
illiberal
because what because we want to restore
some of the normal laws that exist
everywhere else in the world that
existed here 20 30 years ago i don't
think so buster i think we got to do
that i think we got to start wielding
politics
not to not to create some utopian
society but just to go back to the much
more sane society that we had not that
long ago
i'm glad you like that clip now look we
made it to 1 million subscribers that's
really great i'm getting my gold play
button from youtube it's it's fabulous
they haven't nuked me yet wonderful now
next goal
1 trillion i want to get to 1 trillion
subscribers i can't do that without your
help you need to ring ding dong like
subscribe whatever you got to do get the
notifications we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]